7 8 9 10 y hasta 11 veces tercera larga
y fracasada jornada en la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos hacía
100 años que no se tardaba tanto en
escoger presidente de la cámara baja el
nominado del partido republicano Kevin
mccarthy sigue sin conseguir los votos
del estado de California ha recibido 200
votos hay una veintena de republicanos
discos que evitan llegar a la mayoría de
218 necesaria son cercanos a la extrema
derecha e incluso madgets representante
de Florida votó por el expresidente
Donald Trump para el cargo después de
nominarle
pese a los intentos de macarthy de
hablar uno por uno con sus compañeros
Los Rebeldes quieren reducir la
importancia del líder de la mayoría en
la cámara de representantes buscan más
influencia escaños En comités clave y la
capacidad de redactar y modificar
proyectos de ley en un proceso más
abierto el representante republicano por
Pensilvania acusó a sus compañeros de
filtraciones no hay trato cuando se
traicionan las confidencias y se dirigen
las filtraciones es aún más difícil
confiar totalmente insatisfecho no
cederé al statu quo
Los partidarios de macarthy dijeron que
la seguridad nacional está en riesgo sin
una decisión mientras las votaciones las
ha estado liderando el demócrata hakim
jeffries con 212 votos que tampoco tiene
los 218 necesarios para ser el nuevo
líder el viernes habrá una nueva
oportunidad